mai vecchia cosa mi sta succedendo non
riesco a smettere allora io lo farò una
intro superò superò super stai ancora in
quel gioco madonna che che ansia sto
gioco quando parte io l'ho si no
io ho scritto sì allora il suo schifo
mamma mi puzza l'ascella
no ho perso il controllo e mi diceva
caschi il cazzo che vuoi
super 8 prima non mi dai la password ora
questo ti blocco stronzo masi oka soreta
voglio solo tornare nel gioco bene ma
che impera questo tornare il gioco basta
farmi giocare
ecco desiderio esaudito i fanta genitori
a.ge
che cazzo se io volevo fare una intro
non posso fare la intro non posso farla
in 36 st roba ma io volevo giocare a
super 8 che cos'è sto schifo
siamo su super 8 ve lo ricordate il
gioco quello che andava ra lenticolo
figo bene ecco adesso hanno fatto un
aggiornamento ha detto il sistema ti
renderà libero grazie fantastico
sistemati plasmerà e vai piano coi
plasma comunque va bene è lì maggio lo
stesso
si sta chiudendo si sta chiudendo bene
dove chi picco a caso suppo suppo suppo
8 su 8 suppo o succo o credo che questo
sia l'effetto della md non lo so su
supporti sui ponti capi del corpo e
sacrificabili colpe sacrifica ma finora
che cazzo sta cosa sta succedendo
abbandona questo gap satana esci da
questo computer premi e per scambiare il
corpo coi nemici nov abbiamo che figata
è veramente quanto è diventato figlio
sto gioco perché non l'ho più giocato ho
trovato il libro la scuola uccide detto
il premier e per lui c'è immediatamente
subito locali anzitutto cambio il corpo
mi chiama sta cosa i cambi colpo font
estiva prendo la tazza da te cos'è
scambio non trovano mi chiamo lo
scambiamo i con la tazza nove premi la
tazza ti lancio la tazza in bocca
prendo il computer ti lancio computer
non muore
mi scambio con quello che la mazza da
baseball e come scambiano un pronto
scopo ci mette sto scambi a cambiarsi
però c'è mi picchiano mazza da baseball
servizio in camera è sta roba santo
iddio aspetta che c'è quello che c'è un
fucile c'è il fucile aiuto è diventato
difficilissimo ma ce la farò fermi che
la posso fare allora uno seriamente
stavolta bambin vodka uno ti spacco il
cervello
noi cerchiamo aia cazzo mi spara
non ci credo ma non ci credo my back
adryan scambia non ci posso credere
cosa sto facendo premio a schiaffi
prendi l'arma
sono fatto cosa cazzo fatto rega fermi
si possa ho fatto o supporto o una donna
come mi viene duro quando faccio queste
cose non avete idea premi f5 per
modificare le play ma che modificare
replay questa vita vera reallife l'inter
sa che cos'è sta roba scambio del corpo
qual'era l'anime dove facciamo lo
scambio il corpo che non me lo ricordo
più allora quella è morto loschi vato
non chiedetemi come come l'ho ucciso
mario perché se scritta starò aveva
preso il fucile no porca di una crew
devo concentrarmi ce la posso fare
carnici una scala è la madonna quanto
melo su chi ho vinto
l'ho preso l'ho preso una pala cosa te
ne fai di una palla prendi l'estintore
mi chiede schivata cibo per cani
cazzotto in bocca
fantastico grazie della pala vai a
zappare vigna testa di culo a perfetto
finito da poco
ma chi l'aveva visto mai quello
posacenere il fumo uccide quello dove
minchia arriva e vabbè tanto peccati da
dove è arrivato questo ok andata di culo
al massimo contro uno e morto dove dato
è arrivato uno sfigato è veramente
impossibile perché mira di madonna
giorni scommesso madonna mia non lo sa
sparare meglio nonchè 11 ne ucciso forza
[ __ ] lai da barbara guardato video
ecco da dove era arrivato il deficiente
non è che entra qualcuno la valigia sono
una donna possano in cui l'oro mancato
scambio nel corpo vabbè è la piece of
arc solo mi sta sparando in bocca è
tanto mi ucciderà per forza h
il tana vacca dichiararmi durano un
secondo ma con quelle della kiko niente
porca vacca laida porca qua c'è un
treppiede x fi video per farli youtubers
per farlo youtuber mi spiace riodo tardi
magari stronzo posso prenderlo a pugni
così uno specchio proiettino
bolelli non ha mai ucciso forse non ho
ucciso non ci credo mai che ho fatto una
strage incredibile punizione esaurite
perfetto novo dubbi guarda ho preso il
cazzotto in bocca a chi è che manca chi
è che manca fatti avanti patia t strap
che si fa con il modello
[Musica]
e morto per far sì ha ringraziato gesù
cristo
ragazzi ho messo un'ora cioè non avete
idea quanto ci ho messo per questo
livello incredibile non avevo visto che
l'avevano già la giornata pesante beh
più o meno è questo lavoro la youtuber
sempre più difficile salve grazie a me
non so camici stronzi che ci amici amici
e ti sparano sull'appendice fans sei
licenziato e grazie grazie mille a eva
lercia ucciso dio santo benedetto
premier ma veloce
madonna non ci credo non mancato ma non
ci credono al conto sono rincoglionito
daigo fatto vedo se riesco a farlo
veloce ragazzi ci riprova 1 non ho visto
dove l'arma dove l'arma dove l'arma è
rimasta lì porca eva perfetto tastiera
non lo prendo l'ho preso che pur se
licenziato grazie tanto mi fanno mi
piaceva al lavoro di merda ma che bel
lavoro rifai vasili fi e calzi frontier
in faccia così st romano un walkie
talkie pronto pizza perché ho ordino le
pizze golfo di tokyo
la strage non è finita e proviamo si no
con le mie volevi e l'ho ucciso è
materia silmi fa una pippa comunque
perfetto dai e alla prossima non so
quanto dura su nove ragazzi ma epico una
vagina una vagina elettronica una vagina
elettronica con un cervello fatto di
parentesi se il nostro strumento ora per
fare le pagine che useremo per
sconfiggere la vagina no al nemico
dell'inter dall'interno ti servono altri
dettagli no ho capito
credo di aver capisce il semplice al
lavoro subito del dov'è il mio stipendi
quanto mi date di al mese non so e non
sappiamo avere tanto tanto devo pagare
le tasse lo fate voi dove rom per il mio
lavoro consiste nel spaccare le cabine
del telefono
se ti regalo questa valigia e frutta che
tienitela basso eto'o nonna ap a test
immondizia perfetto
thank you non ci credo ma ove belice che
riesca a morire così è uno
forza è male sa quanto sono storto
pakista sparare non c'è nessuno a
pianosa posto con un detto ok cosa
andato pure che chi il giuro che a
vederlo sembra ripeti con me la mente è
software adesso ripeti tuccio la mamma
butta giù la ma la mente software
lamentecontorta vai fuori dove vai fuori
dalle palle
attento a te c'è una cosa dietro europeo
che anche fermi tutti fermi ho iniziato
a giocare a super hot come avete visto
pensando che avessero aggiunto una nuova
modalità ma una roba che durasse tipo 5
10 minuti ecco insomma non è così hanno
aggiunto un'altra storia molto più [ __ ]
di quali prima tra l'altro minisci
faccio più episodi ne faccio cioè non
pensavo perché ve l'ho iniziato credendo
di farne uno invece ne faccio di più
perché porca eva è bellissimo non credo
che la mia tastiera sia d'accordo con
questo però non avete capito il perché
non è d'accordo la mia tastiera h detto
questo dire che possiamo continuare nel
prossimo episodio che diventerà ancora
più figo questo ve lo garantisco quindi
ragazzi per oggi con quello via episodio
e spero che vi sia piaciuto è corso il
ragazzo subito piaciuto al momento è un
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
condivido totalmente scrizione cioè se
non si fischia temi civili diavolo
proseguito belle ragazze
ciao amico clicca anche tu su questi
video belliche vedi sullo schermo
sinistra per vederne uno bello ea destra
per vederne un altro bello più bello e
se non sei iscritto al cai clicca il
tasto soprattutto in un cerchio che ti
iscrivi al canale che ciao